on the hill today for the giants will be
logan webb
jack's right hand are making start
number six one through rec with a 5-3-4
era
so here we go willie calhoun born in
vallejo
and still lives in the off-season in
benicia went to benicia high school
first ball swinging and a
diving catch by talkman
wow what a start to this game
immediate big time action joey hitting
221
after an 0 for 4 in the ball game
yesterday
six home runs 16 runs batted in for
gallow
rangers in their traditional road graze
today they wore their blue tops
yesterday but
the traditional all road gray uniform
today giants in their same
uh all cream home whites here's a ball
hit up the middle crawford the shortstop
has it runs to second for one the throw
to first
double play crawford was on the right
side of the infield there
fielded that on his way to second
rangers might want to look at this
however at least the call at first base
crawford
able to easily force low but it was a
bang bang call at
first he wants it
so they are going to challenge him this
is a run if he's safe
and he is looks like they're close to
ending the
discussion here we go oh he's safe at
first okay
oh god he's got me he dig me
well that is huge a run on the board for
the rangers now
so now david dahl comes up the sixth
hitter of the first inning for texas
two on two out gallow at second solac at
first here's a swing and a miss change
up
got him swinging so after all that what
a grind logan webb
did well to limit the damage made some
big pitches there
and gives up just the one run so as the
giants come up in the bottom of the
first with talkman
and then yostremski and longoria it's
texas one giants coming up
jordan lyles has struggled this year a
7.09 earned run average for the 30 year
old right hander
here's mike yastremski runner at first
nobody out
3-2 talkman runs again stremski rips
this one it's going to be a fair ball
couple hops and right up into the pillar
between the second and third archways
here comes talkman around
third the relay will not even be made
talkman scores
and into second with a double mike
yostremski giants two hitters in
have tied this game it's one to one and
up to the plate steps evan longoria he's
banning 272.
2-2 and a swing and a miss
he strikes out and heim will put the tag
on him for the first out of the inning
now belt who has been hitting
right-handers
very hard lately one to one here in the
first
yostremski knocking in the giants first
run
with a double now belt trying to knock
him in
and he has done it down the right field
live gallows got the great arm but he
juggles the ball
yaz will score easily on a single by
belt
2-1 giants cassalli right-handed hitting
catcher batting just 116.
no home runs but he's knocked in five
the one-two to casalli
is on the outside corner a called third
strike a well-placed slider there
will end the giants half of the first
but san fran with two runs in the inning
on a couple of hits they leave two men
we'll go to the second giants leading
the rangers 2-1
two down and up comes jordan lyles
phillies play the nationals in
washington webb's pitch is swung on and
miss
lyles didn't look all that into that at
that and
logan webb has himself a nice one two
three in it duggar hitting 250 on the
year no home runs and three runs batted
in
the one two swing and a miss and there's
a well located fastball that one was
right at the top of the zone so duggar
strikes out it's the third strikeout
for jordan lyles and it brings up logan
webb the pitcher
one two oh got him with the heat struck
him out
three straight strikeouts now for lyles
low
powerful left-handed hitter walked his
first time
the 2-2 pitch is swung on and missed
strike three through another
change-up and got him to chase third
logan webb strikeout
out number two joey gallo
webb looks back to second conor falefa
takes his lead the pitch is swung on and
missed strike three
great change up there and he threw some
really good ones to both low
and gallow to get through the jam a hit
batter but a runner's stranded rangers
do not score
so with one out the battle will be
cumbersome there goes the runner from
first the pitch is swung on and missed
casalli with the throw to second the tag
by flores and he's out
the rangers indicating that they may
want to challenge him
and that's uh that one should not take
long at all
he's in there well the home plate umpire
corey blazer and the crew chief tom
halley and remove the headsets and he is
in fact
safe heim fouled out to the right
fielder his first time
[Applause]
now the one-two pitch he struck it out
swinging
the slider down and in six strikeouts in
four
for innings webb brandon crawford the
batter one two
swing and a miss nice curve ball there
from lyles sweeping
beneath the zone struck out swinging his
first time
and here it comes and he spins a
curveball in there strike three called
that is the seventh strikeout in four in
the third innings for
logan webb why not nobody on here's
calhoun
now he swings and misses strike three
another slider that
broke down and out of the zone isaiah
kiner falefa
the hitter webb is average 15 pitches
per inning so far
this is his 75th pitch of the game and
he struck him out swinging
he got a change up on the inner part of
the plate
and falefa brought the hands in against
the body and could not make contact
he strikes out the side he has nine
strikeouts in five innings
and here's webb who struck out his first
time up
jordan working off that extreme first
base side of the rubber both pitchers
working out of basically the same spot
on the hill
and a swing and a miss on a fastball and
so webb is dispatched on three pitches
here
two down here is solac now the wind up
here it comes
he struck it out swinging with the
change up
and that's ten strikeouts in six innings
for logan webb here's casalli
trying to get somebody home here
here it comes swinging a hard ground
ball to third backhanded by culberson
the long throw
in the dirt and it's off the glove of
low one run is scored and here comes
crawford
and he will score second day in a row
with a low throw from charlie culberson
and the giants turn it into two runs
here
and it's 401 giants dahl has a hit today
in two tries 3-1 pitch and that one
in the air deep out to left field
carrying pretty well it is gone
a solo home run by david dahl
and it makes it a four to two ball game
and for dahl his third home run of the
year nick zolac another powerful
right-handed hitter coming up now solak
grounds it softly to short crawford
has it his throw to first right there
wilmer flores
foot on the bag for out number three
nicely done zach patel
and the side is retired one hit one
error one strand to dubon flores
crawford coming up
so the big right-handed hitting rough
the former philly standing in
full count to rough here's the pitch
swing and a ball hit on the left side
culverson comes up with that ground ball
and his throw in plenty of time to
retire rough for the final out
in the bottom of the eighth no runs a
hit two men are left will go to the
ninth inning it's still
giants four rangers two garcia
with nobody on mcgee
tries it again he struck him out
the high hard one up out of the strike
zone
in the final analysis he did not have to
throw him a strike
the ball game is over a save for mcgee
and the giants
sweep this two-game series